ce projet libris ou même à l'infini
n'est pas vraiment né à La Réunion
c'est des circonstances particulières
lors d'une résidence un Jaipur en Inde
lors d'un travail que je réalisais sur
un personnalité de où la biche en
terrain dans le solbelia que l'idée est
venue de rendre également un hommage à
des artistes venus de Perse qui était
installés depuis le 12ème siècle dans la
région de Jaipur et de manière générale
en Inde
j'ai réalisé le premier livre
dédié à la grande personne de makayam
poète
très satirique poète de son temps à
partir de ce moment-là je
sculpter le livre comme j'utilisais
beaucoup la terre Grèce à cette époque
moi j'assant
c'était un mélange de matériaux
terre cuite papier
corde et c'est comme ça qu'elle est le
livre de Thomas Kayam qui aujourd'hui
est un exposition permanente au musée
de beaux-arts de Jaipur
[Musique]
cette idée de dommage au poète la poésie
c'est parce que moi-même de temps en
temps j'arrive à quelques fois à écrire
à mettre des mots que je donne ma tête
sur papier
lavage de 14 15 ans mon père nous a
construit une bibliothèque ça a été
l'objet central de la salle du salon et
où lui-même
beaucoup accumulé comme livre et tout il
nous disent nous inciter ils nous disait
que dans cet espace se trouve peut-être
c'est la liberté d'expression la liberté
de travailler d'être libre
faites toujours référence olive et aux
mots le mot des autres qui pourrait
également nous nous apporter beaucoup
plus bleu lumière beaucoup plus de
choses à notre vie personnelle
intérieure mes frères et moi on
fréquentait donc énormément cette
bibliothèque dans lequel il était bien
sûr à cette époque c'était par image et
on avait besoin d'images de ce qui s'est
passé dans le monde c'est à dire que
j'ai les conservé
on a tellement fait de déménagements
tellement j'ai tellement participé
tellement partie à droite à gauche ça a
été un nomadisme un conventurable pour
moi donc mais sa bibliothèque je vais
amener là où j'allais aujourd'hui je
dois peut-être la rénover un peu parce
que la pris des coups comme nous même
nous avons pris
c'est important que que reste un peu un
symbole accroché comme ça dans mon
environnement et où les gens peuvent
venir également retrouver des livres
retrouver la poésie et retrouver
comme ça le sens de l'histoire à
l'intérieur de ce meuble
on voit légèrement et rouge massif
c'est un souvenir tout à fait profond
tout à fait réac tout à fait en prise
avec ma propre vie
sa bibliothèque regorgeait de revues de
livres qu'il achetait qui faisait venir
et ça nous permettait de de connaître un
peu l'histoire qui se passait à ce
moment-là les années 60 les années 50 60
70 que ben il y avait les grands
mouvements politiques du monde avec la
conférence de Mango par exemple le
visage
très important de Gandhi
Mandela en prison voilà on découvrait le
monde et je crois que c'était petit à
petit bonne conscience et de l'état du
monde et puis en faire partie également
parce que bon d'origine vietnamienne on
s'est intéressé énormément à ce qui
s'est passé au Vietnam et là
d'une manière très importante on a vu le
visage de chimine du vietnamine on
apprenait vraiment ce qui se passait à
côté chez nous et cette prise de
conscience était importante pour
l'avenir de moi-même et de mes frères et
de tout le monde et mon père c'était un
lecteur vraiment incroyable il lisait
tout il disait de tout et donc il nous a
appris également à être dans le livre à
être dans la poésie aussi donc voilà
donc je crois que l'hybride vient de là
viens de mes 14 15 ans de 18 ans 20 ans
revenir un peu et demander et faire pour
la poésie pour les poètes c'était très
important
que j'ai fait avec les artistes en
2004 Haïti un travail avec le fer vaudou
tu as ici des des divinités de l'espace
vaudou et donc j'ai repris tout ça
alors là pour l'instant il y a un
personnage avec un animal
alors bien sûr le rouge noir et blanc
sont les symboles comme
tous ces cérémonies
alors bien sûr quelquefois d'une manière
tout à fait intime je mets le visage
donc de Franck Étienne voilà pour donner
uniquement Franck Étienne qui présente
un petit peu Haïti un petit peu le monde
caribéen en fait
parce que c'est vrai que si je voulais
je pourrais t'envoyer sur des poètes
Cuba il y en a énormément c'est très
très grand donc il y aura lui et puis
Neruda pour l'Amérique latine
et là j'ai mis le poème de galerie
la mémoire
il est dans l'eau tu vois là alors bien
sûr ce qui m'intéresse aussi c'est les
l'évaporation de loi d'intérieur de
cette boîte qui est fermée
immatriquement qui sera fermé
automatiquement parce que là on a une
plaque là
et qui va être ensuite commis
nous donne comme possibilité de poésie
que ça couverture éventuellement et puis
ça
fait pour l'encre alors je ne sais pas
j'ai essayé de trouver l'encre qui
allait dans l'eau et qui pouvait rester
donc ça fait un mois que c'est là
donc là c'est une expérience en fait je
sais pas trop où je vais mais c'est une
expérience qui va peut-être me permettre
de laisser cette écriture dans l'eau
comme une page qui se trouve dans le
sérieux indien il mettant quand même une
fois ou deux d'avoir trouvé des
bouteilles dans l'eau avec les messages
oh pas à la Réunion
en travaillant dans dans l'océan à la
recherche de
les options tombés dans l'eau les
moments les plus importants par rapport
à la poésie c'est passé par l'école bien
entendu donc j'avais des professeurs qui
me faisaient lire Rimbaud
tous les poissons
quelques poètes de Lille et
donc cet hommage part justement de cette
relation c'est le contact de lecture
avec la poésie et
j'étais quelqu'un quand même de dire
sensible à cela et souvent je prenais ma
plume beaucoup de mes poésies ce que
j'écrivais quand j'étais beaucoup plus
jeune ils ont disparu bien entendu mais
bon mais ça a été un début un contact
une vers cette réalité politique cette
expression souvent
assoupi en nous
garder précieusement et qui un jour pour
des raisons X peu importe va sortir se
répandre sur une feuille blanche
c'est
cet état d'âme qui fait que le mot
compose c'est un mot qui vient de loin
de chez nous de l'Intérieur donc un cri
de l'âme
il y a des îles
grandes îles
presque
continent éparpiller dans les mers et
les océans
grain de beauté du monde
il enchaînait depuis l'oeuvre des temps
du sucre
il remplit dans puissants mémoire des
forêts
il a sa submergé et rongé par des océans
profonds
soufflant dans l'amour leur sport 1000
couleurs de peau
il a Jacquot qui danse la misère du
monde dans la rage des sorciers
il enchappe pour conjurer l'histoire
amer du sang noir
il a parfois oublié
de réponse
il volcan gardien du feu sacré de la
terre
et il est des solitudes sans fond ou se
consume la vie des Parisiens
il cachait dans la brume aux raisonne le
chant des sirènes en exil
il a l'arbitre ou se distille dans la
rumeur des grands larges le credo des
peurs
il de glace cathédrale dressée comme des
diamants à la surface du temps et
mémorial
il désire refuge de la pensée de
l'oiseau migrateur
il y a des îles sans nom
qui martelent depuis leur naissance le
mot liberté aujourd'hui on peut prendre
n'importe quel livre aller dans
n'importe quel médiathèque bibliothèque
on peut relire
Mallarmé Baudelaire le Prévert
et puis des potes de chez nous
la mère me prend par la ville
la mère me prend
par la ville
le poète doit
raconter sa ville et doit dire qu'elle
est belle
la vie donc la mère me prend par la
ville pour compter au marines du Pôle
Nord rappelez-moi Bruce bien Malika pour
compter
faut compter au marine
du Ponant c'est un joli mot c'est un
pôle Nord
pour compter au marines du Ponant donc
font Titan côté ponton c'est un endroit
de connait bien
dans le fonds
faut pas oublier l'endroit où sont
dans le
les jouets
non désolé cocooba d'accord
chanson
[Musique]
toute la ville descend vers la mer
pour le port
toute la ville
descend de la mer pour retrouver cette
arme qui nous fut donné
c'est un m'a donné donc il m'a donné
dans la page d'un pleurer et elle m'a
donné donc elle m'a donné donc bouillon
massalé mon mal barré
son grand CV tombe dans son rosier la
salive
j'ai voulu dans la présentation des
poèmes
trouver un support qui soit différent
que le livre dans lequel on peut écrire
le poème
il s'agissait surtout au des poèmes de
l'Orient
de la Perse de l'Iran de l'Inde
alors j'ai beaucoup réfléchi j'ai choisi
le cheval cet animal emblématique
très très présent dans la culture de ces
pays
depuis des millénaires on peut parler de
la Route de la Soie des conquêtes et des
échanges culturelles entre ce pays
[Musique]
et
c'est très très bien dans la mesure où
j'ai trouvé la personne ne Cindy par
umano silice couturière une motivation
et une sensibilité
pour l'habillage du cheval en terre
cuite
c'est la morphologie du cheval qui a
apporté beaucoup et donc de trouver des
matériaux les tissus en fonction de ces
pays et des couleurs qu'on utilise
c'était une manière très créative de
choisir de réaliser de composer le tissu
il s'agissait bon pour nous en utilisant
le corps de la bête de créer un espace
original singulier qui met en relation
la pensée donc ensuite le poème et
l'animal
l'animal est un celui qui transporte des
grands espaces vers la cité les
problèmes épiques du persan au macaillam
de l'afghanomie et du bengalitagor
parler de la poésie
dans notre île dans nos îles sur nos
continents
d'où nous venons
c'est quelque chose de très important
c'est-à-dire en fait avec notre histoire
propre et donc si je parle de Boris
gamalia si je voudrais faire le livre
d'Alain Lorraine
c'est parce que ces personnes ont été
très importantes ils ont été vraiment
des lumières pour nous et on peut on
pouvait à travers leur création
bien comprendre le comment ce qui se
passait dans la tête des gens de
Savannah usine bonne à tout faire près
de la ravine écoute bien nous voir dans
la nuit au grand cochon du mensonge avec
notre blouse avec notre musique en
cuivre et notre tam-tam nous quittons en
arrière cours esclavage et nous arrivons
en face de la lumière
le malgache de la guerre exorcise de la
ténèbres le petit blanc hors du usage de
blanchittes de cherches sans lendemain
et dans saint et dans ce mariage le port
n'est pas assez beau et parle créole
l'esclavage et ta fleur de peau et nous
voici et nous voici jusqu'au
bout de la peau je ne dis pas un aigre
de couleur mais de combat comme
luumba d'Afrique n'a grande liberté avec
ses mandats cela plus haute montagne
bidonville nègre-choffre ta
boule créole de canton
d'Arabie rescapé recalé interdit de ce
jour dans de langage étrangers venu de
la fraude à succès
tout oublier jusqu'à demain matin ne
plus être cet homme tout venant qui ne
va nulle part ce Comédie Française
fêtons fêtant la musique qui fait naître
les racines fait-on pour ne plus se
perdre pour pouvoir y croire
la poésie à la Réunion aujourd'hui c'est
également la voie des femmes alors bien
je parlerai d'abord de Jean Brézé qui
c'est là où j'ai pu moi à une époque
connecter avec ce qui se
traduisait en termes de poésie
aujourd'hui plus près de chez nous c'est
vrai qu'il y a kaloon Marie cissaï
Claire Kaam
et ce sont des voies féminines très
puissantes je tendance à dire également
que
le poète
c'est la voix c'est notre voix
qui raconte le pays qui raconte la mère
l'océan qui raconte la matière qui
raconte des arbres et
ce sont des voix
qu'on peut vraiment entendre de très
très loin alors il faut vous dire que
l'hybride c'est pas seulement mon
travail je vais parler des gens qui
écrivent ce qui écrit la poésie de
l'autre je dois j'ai quand même à des
femmes qui sont venues qui est très
intéressants et qui ont fait ce travail
de recopier c'est le script qui recopie
comme à l'ancienne la poésie de Caballé
il y a la poésie des nerudes dans la
poésie de la Chine du Vietnam de l'Inde
du Rajasthan etc
m'y apprend le créole lui apprend il y a
quand même mais après on a écrit
pour écrire et apprendre la graphie la
graphie de Daniel Waro la graphie de
Jean Albanie pour écrire il faut d'abord
que midi
plusieurs fois le texte la parole
et après il commence à écrire
les deux langues
pas Daniel Waro le créole le texte
suivant mon nom
qui est traduit en français
et donc c'est une c'est un c'est une
découverte c'est une belle découverte
pour moi de gloire c'est cette cette
mise en perspective des deux langues que
nous l'a toujours utilisé le français et
le créole les quant c'est écrit comme ça
c'est c'est vraiment passionnant maman
il crache crache toutes nos
frères et
ses fleurs moi mes frères et mes sœurs
la mère et la marche même petite la
hache coupe le gros bois sans peur c'est
un article qui a été parmi les paroles
passagères ou qui passait parmi les
paroles passagers c'est paru dans Le
Courrier international du 21 août 2008
et donc ce n'est pas si vieux que ça
ne laisse pas indifférent
parce que ça veut dire quand même
beaucoup de choses surtout alors sortez
de votre terre de notre mère notre blé
de notre sel de notre blessure de toute
chose sortez des souvenirs de la mémoire
quelque soit les poètes sont venus même
et ça ça m'a vraiment beaucoup touché
claire karmée venu
antérobert Patrice retard ils sont venus
et à un moment donné il s'est passé
quelque chose de magique dans dans mon
atelier où il venait eux-mêmes dessiner
ou
écrire leur propre poésie
ça a été une collection tout à fait
extraordinaire